The box office may be dominated by sequels,
prequels and reboots these days, but when
a movie can stand on its own, it's truly a
success.
But sometimes the movies that seem the most
original, most unique, or just the most successful
can hide serious links to other movies - even
establishing a shared movie universe audiences
never knew to look for.
Until now.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Secret Relations
Between Popular Films.
Avengers: Age of Ultron & Castle in The Sky
The second Avengers team-up saw Marvel's best
take on an evil robot, hellbent on lifting
a city into the sky using cutting-edge technology.
But it's not exactly an original idea.
Marvel fans may not have seen or heard of
Castle in the Sky, Miyazaki's first animated
movie released through the world famous Studio
Ghibli.
But the movie also happened to feature a floating
city, not to mention robots of its own.
Did Ultron get his idea from the same animated
film?
The answer might be clear, once you catch
one of the movie's thin-limbed robot protectors,
rendered in 3D inside the Tony Stark's Avengers
Tower.
Star Wars & E.T.
The Extraterrestrial
Since Steven Spielberg was one of the only
people to guess that Star Wars would be a
massive success, it only seems right for him
to include a nod in his own story of an alien
encounter.
When Elliot takes E.T. out trick-or-treating,
a kid in a Yoda costume walks by, with E.T.
seeming to recognize the other alien visitor.
It was just a playful joke, but George Lucas
doubled down, making sure to include members
of E.T.'s race in his own Galactic Senate,
establishing that E.T. and Yoda really were
neighbors in the very same galaxy.
Memento & The Dark Knight Rises
You might think all the movies have in common
is dire tor Christopher Nolan, but a supporting
character suggests they take place in the
same universe.
Actor Thomas Lennon is the key, having first
played a young, unnamed doctor in Nolan's
fragmented Memento.
When filming began on the final chapter of
his Dark Knight Trilogy, Lennon got a call
to once again appear as Bruce Wayne's personal
doctor.
Lennon played the same character, admitting
that he assumed it was the same doctor - which
meant, to him at least, the Batman story was
all taking place in the damaged brain of Memento's
hero, Leonard Shelby.
Spy Kids & Machete
From the moment director Robert Rodriguez
met Danny Trejo on the set of Desperado, he
began writing an entire film around his intimidating,
ruthless personality, picturing 'Machete'
as a Latin action hero.
But before he could make the movie, Rodriguez
moved onto the family-friendly Spy Kids series.
Seeing an opportunity, he cast Trejo as the
kids' Uncle Machete, eventually cutting a
mock trailer for a standalone movie as part
of the Grindhouse double feature.
Two feature films would follow, making Uncle
Machete a memorable figure with two completely
different audiences.
Collateral & The Transporter
Before Jason Statham was a certified action
star, he made a name for himself in director
Guy Ritchie's tales of London crime - with
Lock, Stock and Two Smoking Barrels his first.
Tom Cruise was apparently a fan, looking to
star in a Hollywood remake.
That never happened, but Statham did land
a small role in Cruise's Collateral - a scene
that meant much more to Statham's fans.
It's easy to see why most view the cameo as
an appearance by Frank Martin, the star of
The Transporter series.
It's never stated outright, but Statham arriving,
delivering a bag, and asking no questions
is more than enough proof for fans.
The Rock & Armageddon
Movie fans know that director Michael Bay's
movies tend to look alike - but there's actual
evidence to suggest they take place in the
same shared universe.
At least, two of his most famous might.
When the American President had to order an
airstrike on hostages held on Alcatraz, Bay
turned to actor Stanley Anderson for the job.
Just a few years later, when an asteroid was
heading towards Earth in Armageddon, Bay called
on the exact same actor to deliver yet another
speech.
Compared to the rest of the two movies, hearing
they're set in the same fictional timeline
isn't actually that hard to believe.
Alien & Spaceballs
It's the original Star Wars saga that Spaceballs
is parodying, but a single joke teases that
in THIS galaxy far, far away, Ellen Ripley
and her crew also ran into the unforgettable
monsters of the Alien movie series.
How else do you explain the presence of actor
John Hurt, reprising his role as the unfortunate
victim of an alien chestburster?
In this universe, it's obviously not as serious
an injury.
Star Trek & Star Wars
Can a single person really unite the two most
famous space franchises in history?
Fans have director JJ Abrams to thank for
linking the two series, including one of the
iconic R2 droids in not just the Star Trek
reboot, but in the sequel, Star Trek Into
Darkness.
Audiences can still play favourites between
Trek and Wars, but on the big screen, a pair
of easter eggs means they no longer have to.
The Fast and The Furious & Herbie: Fully Loaded
As crazy as the world of the Fast & Furious
may have become, cars are still cars - not
intelligent members of the cast.
At least, not EVERY car in the franchise's
universe.
At the end of the first movie, Dominic Toretto
accidentally totals his prized Dodge Charger
before running from the police.
But fans will have to look to Herbie the Lovebug
to find out what happened to the car after
the crash.
The opening of Herbie: Fully Loaded takes
place in a car-filled junkyard - with Toretto's
Charger sitting front and center.
Now we can only wait until the Fast & Furious
cars start talking themselves.
The Abyss and Terminator 2
The Terminator spawned and entire multimedia
franchise, but fans may not realize that long
before shared universes were all the rage,
James Cameron had crafted his own.
Aside from using the exact same news reporter
in the first Terminator movie as his underwater
adventure The Abyss, the company funding the
undersea oil mining operation is known as
Benthic Petroleum.
The logo will look familiar, since it's the
same logo subtly plastered over the gas station
Sarah and John Connor visit in Terminator
2: Judgment Day.
Those are all the subtle, sneaky, or downright
invisible links between hit movies that we
could find, but which ones do you know of
that we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!